marisa es un amante de los gatos
actualmente cuida de varios pero no
puede resistirse a adoptar otro pequeño
y adorable amigo peludo después de
mudarse a una casa más grande
marisa comienza a adoptar gatos a un
ritmo constante el número de gatos en la
nueva casa de marisa g como función del
tiempo desde que se mudó en días t se
ilustra en la gráfica a continuación en
esta gráfica de acá abajo basándote en
la gráfica cuál de las siguientes
proposiciones es correcta y aquí me dan
varias opciones vamos a checar cada una
y vamos a ver que podemos deducir marisa
tenía 10 gatos cuando se mudó de casa y
adopta dos nuevos gatos cada día bueno
veamos marisa se mudó de casa en el día
0 el día 0 de su primer día en la nueva
casa por lo tanto los gatos que tuvieran
el día 0 serían los gatos con los que
llegó a su casa nueva por lo tanto aquí
veo que entre igual a 0 si se
corresponde a 10 gatos puedo decir que
el punto 0 10 está en la gráfica por lo
tanto cuando se acaba de mudar
si tenía 10 gatos entonces esta parte es
correcta y adopta dos nuevos gatos cada
día bueno para ver eso lo que vamos a
hacer es tratar de calcular a qué ritmo
es tamaris adoptando gatos
vamos a ver necesito encontrar otro
punto sobre la gráfica que sea fácil de
leer que tenga coordenadas sencillas no
es que no esté en este punto es bueno
este punto aquí parece que tiene
coordenadas 15,40
este es el punto 15,40 con estos dos
puntos voy a tratar de calcular a qué
ritmo está adoptando gatos marisa que de
hecho eso equivale a encontrar la
pendiente de esta línea recta pero bueno
veamos si pasamos de 0 de 0 gap perdón
de 0 días hasta 15 días entonces tengo
un cambio un cambio en el tiempo de 15
días 15 días y qué pasó con el número de
gatos pues cambio de estar en 10 a
llegar hasta 40 mar y se está adoptando
gatos a una velocidad bastante bastante
rápida y de hecho en algún momento
tendría que parar en la vida real pero
como es un problema de matemáticas
podemos realizarlo así que paso de aquí
de estar a 10 a estar a 40 por lo tanto
el cambio el cambio en la cantidad de
gatos ventaje es igual a 40 menos 10 que
es 30
de donde la velocidad con la que marisa
está adoptando gatos sería igual a el
cambio del número de gatos dividido
entre el cambio en el tiempo
correspondiente al cambio del número de
gatos el cambio número de gatos decía
que era 30
y el cambio en el tiempo era 15 por lo
tanto marisa adoptar 30 gatos cada 15
días o lo que es lo mismo 2 gatos cada
día 2 gatos por cada unidad de tiempo
que son días por lo tanto es cierto que
adopta dos nuevos gatos cada día
y bueno esto es opción múltiple así que
probablemente esta sea la respuesta
correcta pero vamos a checar las demás
marisa tenía tres gatos cuando se mudó
de casa y adopta dos nuevos gatos cada
día pues sabemos que no tenía tres gatos
tres gatos sería si la gráfica pasará
por aquí más o menos pero sabemos que
tenía 10 gatos cuando llego así que esto
no es cierto
marisa tenía 10 gatos cuando se mudó esa
parte cierta y adopta un nuevo gato cada
dos días pues no acabamos de calcular
que adopta dos gatos cada día por lo
tanto esto tampoco tiene sentido marisa
tenía tres gatos cuando se mudó de casa
y adoptar un nuevo gato cada dos días de
nuevo tres gatos está mal noten
finalmente que la pendiente de esto sí
tiene sentido si maris adopta dos gatos
cada día entonces después de 15 días el
número de gatos debía haber aumentado en
30 que es precisamente lo que sucede
aquí así que bueno la primera respuesta
es la correcta